Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
He mentions that repentance has three
conditions
if it does not involve the rights of
another human being.
Meaning it's a sin that was committed
between the servant and Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
There's no other human being that has
been wronged in this way.
Then it has three conditions. Repentance
has three conditions. He mentions three
of them.
He mentions ceasing the act immediately.
He mentions the second condition
condition which is to have contrition
and
regret for what has passed for what
he did for having done the sin. And
the third having sincere
earnest intention never to go back to
doing that sin again.
Other
scholars have added two more conditions
to this.
So they add that
repentance has five conditions.
What are the other two additions?
Number one, they mention intentions.
Intentions.
Because a person may cease
a sin
but with the wrong intention.
For instance, let's say a person who
drinks alcohol regularly and they start
to get
sick from this and they get liver
disease for instance and so they pledge
to never drink alcohol again. Not
necessarily because it is a sin
but because of the illness. The illness
has driven them to this.
Or for instance because of doctor's
orders or because any particular sin
their spouse doesn't it or
something that. So there's a number
of reasons why a person may
leave off a sin for the wrong reasons.
In order for it to be a repentance, it
has to be left off for the sake of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. And that has to be
the driving force behind a person's
repentance.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
that there are people who regret
and they have these conditions of
repentance but for the wrong reason.
So for instance, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala mentions the most important
condition of repentance which is regret
contrition. As a matter of fact, the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said
he said contrition is repentance.
Meaning that embodies repentance. That's
the most important part of repentance is
that a person is contrite that a person
is mournful, regretful for having done
the sin.
But
he mentions subhanahu wa ta'ala
individuals in the Quran
who do not repent and who are not
forgiven but also have regret.
for instance,
when he killed his brother,
he was very contrite.
Allah tells us he was very regretful for
having killed his brother. However, that
wasn't a repentance. Why? Because he was
regretful for the wrong reasons. He was
regretful not because he had disobeyed
Allah. He was regretful because of the
repercussions of his actions.
For this reason, the prophet Sam
said,
[Silence]
"The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said regarding
who had killed his brother that from
that day forward no blood is spilled, no
innocent is murdered
except that
has a portion of that sin because he is
the first one to
start the tradition of murder. You
disagree with someone, kill them, right?
And that's obviously the most extreme,
but there are other ways to harm people
in disagreement. And so
if he had repented and if his repentance
was accepted,
then he would not be held responsible
for everyone who is killed after him.
Another condition that some of the
scholars mention is that repentance take
place during a time when repentance is
accepted.
Meaning that repentance
is accepted during all time except for
two times.
Two instances where
repentance is not accepted.
one that is specific to individuals and
another that is general for all of
humanity.
The specific time when repentance is not
accepted
is when a person's soul is being
extracted from his body.
He says,
"Indeed Allah accepts the repentance of
any slave that repents to him as long as
he is not
in a state of having his soul extracted
from his body at death." When the angel
of death comes, when a person now sees
the hereafter, when a person knows that
there's no chance to go back to the
dunya, when they see what the hereafter,
what they are headed towards,
everybody repents. There's nothing
special about that. Everyone, even
repents, evenl will repent. This is not
specific, right? This is this is not
unique rather. So this is a time when
repentance would not be accepted.
Another time which is general
and that is when the sun rises from the
west.
When the sun rises from the west,
repentance will not be accepted. Why?
Because everyone will repent at that
moment.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam says in
the narration of Muslim
[Silence]
he saysam
indeed Allah does extend his hand in the
night so that the sinner of the day will
repent to him and he extends his hand in
the day so that the sinner of the night
will repent and he continues to do so
until the sun rises from the west
meaning once the sun the sun rises from
the west as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
states in
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says that when
the sun rises from the West and other
major events happen,
no one will be benefited by his new
found faith upon
encountering these
these major signs of Allah.
He was happy. Alhamdulillah.